et si johnny n'avait jamais existé c'est
le thème d'un très joli film tout
simplement intitulé jean-philippe signé
laurent tu l est qui est présenté ce
soir en avant première à l'ugc ciné cité
de l'ill jean philippe raconte
l'histoire d'un fan absolu de johnny
incarné par fabrice luchini qui se
réveille un beau matin dans un monde où
la star n'a jamais existé pour fêter le
500e numéro de voie publique j'ai donc
l'immense plaisir de recevoir monsieur
johnny halliday bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir
et j'ai envie de poser la première
question qui est celle qui le fil rouge
de cette émission et si johnny
n'existait pas comment vous à wes ap ap
ben ça c'est pas plus mal fort
honnêtement
ben pourquoi vous les bords vous êtes en
train de me chambrer quand vous ne savez
pas plus que ça c'est pas plus mal
ben c'est pas plus mal non non non ça ne
serait pas plus mal
c'est beau pourquoi j'existe très bas
pour nous faire vibrer sur vos jambes et
pensez vous que jean-philippe puisse
changer donc que ce film puisse changer
l'image de la star absolue que vous
incarnez pour vos femmes mais moi j'ai
aimé faire ce film pour une seule raison
c'est que ça change un petit peu l'image
que j'ai et que l'essor des films c'est
cij
si johnny d n'a jamais existé trouve
entre jeunes et aider à travers jean
fils jean-philippe smet et vous vous
l'avez trouvé jean philippe smet
je suis né avec ninon et comme vous le
chantier mais j'avais je ne l'aï jamais
trouvé dommage est j'ai travaillé à
travers sa d'avant personnage alors si
vous voulez bien on va tous y de voir la
bande annonce de ce film fabrice et
jean-philippe dans leurs oeuvres jean
philippe
ce pays parte a retrouvé inanimé dans la
rue veut me faire le coffret collector
l'apia 2000
[Musique]
on m'a volé tous mes disques de johnny
hallyday sans compter la collection
d'objets collectors et discret qui la
pièce how dans le grenier c'est une
blague
si justin bieber vient ici demi coque
d'à peine 20 ans depuis toujours
[Musique]
j'ai the wall voilà
ils sont
m
bye
alors johnny hallyday se jean-philippe
que vous incarnez dans dans dans les
fictions mais il n'est pas du tout mais
alors vous incarnez ce avec tellement de
justesse tellement j'allais dire
d'humilité même d'autodérision vous
moquer de vous comment avez vous réussi
à vous quand vous manquez de vendée a
demandé de faire un sans fils fait qu'il
ait jamais de vie john et idées alors
comment voulez vous que je fasse j'ai
fait à geof expliqué j'avais attendu
tant jean-philippe justement interprète
toute la musique que j'aime devant un
parterre de pensionnaires d'un hospice
c'est ainsi que parce que parce que
parce que fabrice luchini qui veut
devenir mon manager m'a briefé et
voulait que je devienne chanteur donc
j'ai appris les chansons je suis
d'accord mais vous avez dans ce film
vous êtes même trailer il m'a fait
chanter ça mais à te vendent à ce fils
ben oui mais quand même
et puis même même dans ce film on vous
traite de vieux schnock deviez cheney
oui belge faire du stock
si vous le prenez aussi bien c'est
d'ailleurs parce que en plus c'est une
femme que aux défis que j'adore quelqu
es bâbord maintenant et que j'adore mais
non c'est un film godel
vous savez il ya des tas de choses qu'on
aime qu'on n'aime pas celui-là j'ai vu
et le faire bon voilà je les fais je
pense que vos fans aimeront et de
répliques ce soir j'ai deux fans qui
vous envoie deux mails si johnny
n'existait pas fan de johnny depuis ses
débuts écrit maryvonne mon premier
concert mon premier autographe date du
31 octobre 1963 à l'éden de mouscron je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez un coup
de déprime dit-elle jambes jeu mais
johnny et ça repart dans une
cinquantaine d'années écrit jean-claude
juste après l'agrandissement du musée
johnny hallyday qui aura été inaugurée
par le fils de jade mes petits enfants
apprendront que tu es décédé que tu as
reçu des funérailles nationales comme je
ne serai plus là pour en parler avec toi
dit-il jean-claude merci de me dire ce
que tu penses de cette idée de
funérailles nationales
allez on jette à l'eau johnny ben je
reproche pas grand chose
je pense que c'est c'est pas terrible
vous êtes une star absolue ce serait
dommage absolue je ne suis pas une star
les gens s'imaginent ça moi je suis un
homme ça vous savez je veux avec le
batteur moi j'ai une petite jade
aujourd'hui il est déjà acquis ma fille
que j'aime
vous savez quand je me réveille qu'elle
va regarder en face et qu'elle va sauver
et qu'elle dit papa elle a dit jiwa chez
les fai belles choses en le rachetant
fou c'est ce qui vous fait continuer à
aimer la vie comme vous l'avez toujours
et ce qui me fait continuer d'être ce
que je suis et ça ça me ça continue je
continue à être jeune à cause de sa voix
jeunes à 62 ans
voilà je suis encore jeune en disant
parce que je dois pour ma vie ben je
vous le souhaite je vous souhaite un
coup en tout cas je ne lis des mercis et
puis longue vie à johnny et à jean
philippe et nous allons recevoir dans un
théâtre à jade et alex et je vais
recevoir dans un instant fabrice luchini
juste après avoir écouté le thé les
répondeurs de voie publique ce soir
[Musique]